folks I have a simple philosophy that
government should work for everyone not
just the elite and that's why I helped
pass the farm bill because I care about
farmers but I won't stop there I will
work for everyone whether you are young
whether you are old whether you are
Asian or Hispanic
whether you are straight or whether you
are gay I will work for all of you and
that's why I also support marriage
equality
folks don't choose to be gay anymore
than I choose to be straight could you
imagine if someone told you that you
couldn't marry the person that you loved
I'm sorry
I think gays are people too gays are not
different gays they are just like us
they love they fear they raised their
children they strive for a better life
but there are those who believe that
being gay is an abomination that's
absurd
the homosexual community is a valuable
community in this country they are
doctors they are lawyers they are
teachers they are me and they are you
and their contributions are no less
important than any other group in this
fine nation of ours so turn to that gay
person near you and see that they are no
different than you are thank you
[Applause]
you